good morning believe nation today's
message is know what your job is over to
you Bryan Cranston awake mode in
espresso TV goes well the best the best
advice for fellow actors is this know
what your job is about 18 years ago I
had this cognition that I realized I was
going in to audition trying to get a job
and that simply wasn't what I was doing
I wasn't what I said what I'm supposed
to be doing an actor is supposed to
create a compelling interest in town
that serves the text we presented in
where your audition
and then you walk away and that's it
everything else is out of your control
so don't even think of it don't focus on
that you're not going there to get a job
they're going there to present what you
do you act and there it is and walk away
when there's power in that there's
confidence in them and it's also saying
I can only do so much and then the
decision of who might get a job is so
out of your control that it really when
you analyze it it makes no sense to hold
on to that that to me was a breakthrough
and once I adapted that philosophy I
never looked back and I've never been
busier in my life and once I grabbed on
to that this is a really important
message because even though Brian is
talking about knowing what your job is
in the context of being an actor it's
still really important to know as an
entrepreneur as well some days you wake
up and the most important thing that you
need to do is go out and get your sales
and marketing efforts going and that's
the hat that you need to wear today some
days you wake up and you need to have
more innovation in your business and you
need to put your crazy hat on for the
day some days you might feel over
stressed and overworked then you need to
put on your vacation had just to chill
out for a little while as entrepreneurs
we have to wear many different hats and
the most important question you can ask
yourself is you get to your office or
home office or place of work every day
is what's the most value that I can
bring to my business today so my
question of the day today is what hat
are you wearing today leave it in the
comments and I'm going to join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching have an amazing day continue to
believe and I'll see you again tomorrow
morning for another shot events presto
this prey so give me go